[Musik]
hallo herr pfarrer sell israel heute
gibt's ein kleines grundrezept und zwar
weil ich einen plan zeigt zubereiten und
auf diesem brand zeigt macht die
windbeutel windbeutel gab ich auf meinem
kanal noch keine arbeiten die bei uns in
der familie wirklich sehr beliebt meine
schwester die macht die wirklich zu
jedem geburtstag das heißt nicht in die
schon von meiner kindheit auf und habt
ihr auch schon in ganz jungen jahren
immer gebacken windbeutel mag ich ganz
gerne mit nach füllung derzeit noch
werden so wie heute
oder auch mit noch cassano zum beispiel
ich sage ich jetzt erst einmal wie man
diesen windbeutel vorstellt und später
gebt abfüllung also sage ich nicht hier
fahren immer kurz die zutaten für die
windbeutel brauche ich 60 gramm butter
250 milliliter wasser eine prise salz
bekommen und etwa drei bis vier eier für
den brand
nehmt ihr jetzt die total bekommen sie
in einen topf und da kommt auch gleich
noch wasser mir das so gemeinsam mit der
prise salz und die drei zutaten die muss
erst einmal aufkochen lassen
[Musik]
sobald die zutaten kochen kommt jetzt
das mehl mit seinen einen schwung und
jetzt müsst ihr kräftig rühren dann ist
ein großer zeitlos wilders
[Musik]
von diesen zeitlos und den ring ist zwei
bis drei minuten
30 vereine ihn ab und nicht an ich mich
früher uns hier unten bilde sich jetzt
ein schöner weißer belag und ist auch
ganz wichtig dass schritt wenn jetzt
nämlich nicht nachgehen die windbeutel
später nicht schön aus
habe ich lange genug ab programm hier
die gruppe die lustig übrigens von ganz
alleine
das heißt ihr könnt jetzt einfach
abkühlen lassen und dann später gut 18
unser top schließlich super einfach
reinigen
jetzt nehme ich immer ein weihnachten
kunden und macht es immer gerne dass
durch die eier erst in andere schüssel
aufschlagen
damit eben keine eierschale mit in der
zeit geht das erste einzel 1
entweder mit dem bug lassen das ist ein
bisschen anstrengend oder mit einem
handrührgerät oder auch mit der maschine
mit einem flachen beispiel
[Musik]
kli
ich feiere drin das ist aber nur ein
bisschen
und am anfang sieht auch so aus als
würde sich das nie verbinden aber ich
muss einfach geduldig sein dafür findet
sich wirklich sehr gut aber wenn er
zeigt auch so fest ist einfach noch
einiges zu nehmen kommt immer darauf an
wie groß die eier sind jetzt das fertige
teig aus der erkenntnis ist dass er
schön glänzt und vom spitzenfussball ein
fachbuch nicht richtig schön wenn das
fest ist dann kann man ihnen einfach
nicht spritzen so dass wir so
anstrengend und sprit worden doch ich
nehme es eigentlich freundin sie nämlich
immer ganz gerne wenn ich windbeutel
macher oder auch erklärte nämlich gerne
zwei ineinander sind sehr stabil aber
trotzdem passieren wenn man vor allem
viele massenhaft dass er einfach
irgendwann reißen kann
wenn sie einfach super stabil und dann
auch noch mal gerne adapter dass die
spritztour eines vorne nicht ausrutschen
kann
mit großem stern schule
[Musik]
wenn ich einfach mein bad place mit
einer dauer back tory und werde cd
windbeutel drauf spritzen auf diesem
teil könnt ihr aber zum beispiel auch
1000 boden stritten und auch erklärt
[Musik]
windbeutel wenn es mit wasser
bestreichen und können dann auch gleich
zu backen werden
[Musik]
so kommt jetzt in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 20 minuten das lernen der
backzeit auf keinen fall offen tür
öffnen denn die zahl wieder zusammen
[Musik]
die windbeutel sind jetzt gepackt und
abkühlen lassen
ich bin auch wirklich hübsch aus dem
partner von hand machen und auf dessen
gesprungen ich werde die füllung
zubereiten und bei mir gibt heute eine
fruchtbare aber im prinzip könnte dies
blieb ihr möchtet das heißt ihr könnt
mit hochschule machen espressobar ihr
könnt mir vanille sahne machen oder auch
ganze pappe
das heißt mit einem kräutertee spielt es
zum beispiel oder mit einer futterstelle
ich es mal die farbe gefährdet alle für
die bettenzahl brauchen 200 gramm gemüse
beeren wir sind es gefahren 5-klatsche
leistungsseite diesen drei neins zu
krass 400 von schlagsahne den hier nach
dem sommer traf 250 tieren sogar als
puffer und etwas von der linksfraktion
jetzt nämlich zuerst einmal die bären
und tolle daran ist dass jetzt diese
jetzt für jede jahreszeit zubereiten
sonst denn ein gefrierfach
das ist ihr auch brauchen
und wenn sie dann sobald sie seien
entweder mit einer gabel vertreten oder
mitunter stammt war es auf dem start mit
egal was hauptsache wir werden einfach
ignoriert
das war's jetzt hier so und setzen
solange ein kochen ist fast mit
flüssigkeit mehr vorhanden ist
wohin sächsischen zeitung to vima die
bahnsteigs lagen
und dafür nehmen gibt einfach die
trainer will die lange ecke stand
[Musik]
jetzt bringt den frischkäse wolle die
bahn ist fertig und jetzt nämlich hier
dieses hochtouren das habe ich auch
einen verlag gesprächen auf dem akku hat
einfach damit danach kühlt es hier mit
das heißt es dass jetzt nur noch hand
waren also nicht mehr halt doch ganz
wichtig da sonst die letzte stufe an der
stelle kommt die sonderfahrt mit sein
und etwas an der extrakt könnt ihr im
prinzip selbst gleich abschmecken auch
genug ist wenn ich gibt einfach noch ein
bisschen puderzucker betreiben
[Musik]
hier habe ich jetzt noch die sonne unter
und vögel natürlich noch ein bisserl ein
extrakt das so
[Musik]
an
die sanitäterin spritzbeutel mit einer
großen stern schüler gefüllt plastik
bestehen und welche die windbeutel
aufschneiden und es geht am besten mit
einem scharfen brotmesser
[Musik]
die windbeutel befüllt werden und dafür
setze ich jetzt einfach auf eine
tortenplatte und die spülung rein
[Musik]
und wenn der mensch selbst gibt ihr weiß
einbindung in diesem vierten schnee
drauf dass drucker der extra frei nicht
schnell das geschmacklich auch super
denn die tat heute nicht da ist hast du
das sagen ich wäre dafür dass der borat
ist das nicht ganz ehrlich sagen ich
weiß nicht genau wie man wenig beute
listig erste halt immer nicht vor der
kamera so ja zum glück auch einfach ein
ich will noch ein
schon komisch dabei die rede vor der
kamera platz aufruft oder hinten kommen
eine premiere war wir können alles außer
hochdeutsch aber siehe da wir können es
anscheinend doch irgendwie falls jetzt
auch noch zukommen habt auf diese
leckeren windbeutel mit der frucht säure
dann geht auffällig - blog.de doch
direkt noch mal ganz genau und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß das
nachmachen und dir noch einen guten
appetit und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal bis dann
[Musik]